[Applaudissements]
compris ce n'est pas un bal masqué c'est
bel et bien halloween ce soir et vous
allez découvrir dans quelques secondes
les tenues des chroniqueurs et vous
allez pouvoir garder ses dvd car ils
seront collector dans quelques années
ces vendront au prix d'or sur ebay et
car il ya ce soir
d'abord avant de vous présenter les
chroniqueurs vous savez que c'est pas un
cyril hanouna elle vendredi
vous le savez ça pour quoi parce que
sinon la nouvelle vendredi soir il fait
du sport la preuve j'ai des images
regarder en direct la chaîne de sport à
l'essai
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cap là sera mon invité et
mélanger
avec quand elle est sortie de la loge de
maquillage et de le styliste dont on ne
savait pas qu'elle était déguisé en fait
parce que c'était une tenue qui lui bien
comment ça va ravissante jeune coiffeuse
mais dit oh mais c'est bien sert à quoi
embêter cheveux est ce que vous savez
[Rires]
par contre une chose est sûre c'est que
vous n'avez pas dû souvent tenir à bas
les uns c'est la première fois vous
envoyez un mail à comme celui-ci oui non
et vous savez que j'ai rêvé de vous y la
belle hier soir c'est vrai et depuis que
depuis que je fréquente l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste je fais des rêves
et cauchemars zarbi oued et autres trucs
alors j'ai pas trop envie de vous en
parlait il ya des photos des fois qu'ils
me viennent comme ça qui me passe par la
tête quand je rêve le soir jeu vidéo il
y avait que nous alors qui est avec vous
à votre avis qui est derrière ce serait
cesser ce squelette
c'est jean michel maire
à jean michel c'est marrant parce que
vous aussi j'ai rêvé de vous je fais des
rêves hyper bizarre en ce moment j'ai
honte mais je préfère pas vous dire que
je vous ai eu enfin bon peut-être qu'une
image apparaîtra aux téléspectateurs un
moment ou un autre mais c'était très
basse et
mesdames et messieurs nous avons là
c'est la mort c'est thierry mot est
marrant thierry parce que
la tête que vous faites leur en ce
moment ne bougeait pas c'est exactement
la tête que font les téléspectateurs
quand vous sortez une vanne le même
c'est normal j'ai un humour mortels et
mesdames et messieurs regarder il est là
le sauvegarder
les jours où il faut avoir les yeux
rouges il ne les a pas et c'est quand il
est capable c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
fallait avoir l'oeil rouge
elle n'a pas envie de rigoler gilles je
vais vous sucer comment vous croyez que
je rentrais sur d8
alors nous avons également christophe
carrière
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir ça changera grand chose
[Rires]
georges de jean pierre françois demis
roussos et jacquouille la fripouille un
petit nouveau nous a rejoint le times et
laissez vous aller l'accueillir comme il
se doit lors sa tête vous à découvrir et
c'est un homme figurez-vous on ne dirait
pas comme ça ils s'appellent miguel de
rennes
[Applaudissements]
il faut l'accepter pour sa première
d'être déguisée en citrouille et en
femme surtout d'ailleurs vous allez
allez distribué quelques bons bruit je
démontrais bienvenus il est avec nous
pour une raison très simple vous m'avez
tellement pourri sur twitter pour qu'il
soit autour de la table alors je vous
l'offre pour ce alors in bertrand
chamerois lui c'est jérôme bellay diane
où vous vous rappelez sa fille bon vous
n'avez pas peur halloween
tout va bien
[Applaudissements]